Speaker 1: You might remember that in advance
of the Derek Shervin verdict, which we got
earlier this week.
The jury was sequestered, but before the jury
was sequestered, Maxine Waters made some comments
that are the subject of significant controversy,
which we already talked about.
Democratic congresswoman from California.
After the jury was sequestered, President
Biden gave his opinion about the case and
it ended up being that there were three guilty
verdicts.
There were there was no violence afterwards.
Maybe there would have been violence had there
been an acquittal, maybe not.
We don't know.
It didn't happen.
That's what we know when we're operating in
terms of what actually took place.
Donald Trump's former secretary, press secretary,
press secretary Kayleigh McEnany, criticized
Joe Biden for commenting before the verdict,
but after the jury was sequestered saying
that presidents should not.
Inflame tensions.
This is beyond parody as the former press
secretary of the insider in chief, Donald
Trump, of course, inciting a violent, riotous
insurrection on January 6th of this year.
These people I mean, satire is you could not
possibly parody what they are saying.
Let's take a look at the video.
If you are allergic to hypocrisy, if you have
an aversion to cringe, I would skip the next
30 seconds of video.
Speaker 3: We heard Judge Cahill go on to
caution elected officials and say, I urge
you not to weigh in just hours before half
a day before the president himself weighs
in.
Look, I'm glad he at least waited until the
jury was sequestered, but I think that the
country is such a tinderbox right now, especially
Minneapolis.
There's so much hurt, so much pain.
And I think it's the role of the president
of the United States to to stay back, to not
inflame the tensions.
I've like that he called the family of George
Floyd.
President Trump did, too.
But it's such a tinderbox moment.
And I think he should have just reserved comment
and said he's praying for the family as we
all are.
Speaker 1: Can you imagine a more hypocritical
statement?
It isn't merely that Donald Trump incited
a ride on January 6th.
He talked about sending in the military during
the George Floyd protests back in the summer
of 2020 to rough people up.
People were protesting the very thing which
Trump reacted by threatening to do more of.
And on and on and on with other examples.
It's just too much.
It's too pathetic.
And by the way, it's not just Kayleigh McEnany,
whose former boss was doing it.
Kayleigh McEnany herself participated in fanning
the flames from November through January by
ginning up anger over a supposedly stolen
election which set the tone for the January
6th riots.
Trump would not have been able to incite the
January 6th riots if there had been silence
about a supposedly stolen election and dominion
and massive dumps and all of this different
stuff from November to January, the whole
environment from November to January.
And the, you know, Mike Pelo on Newsmax talking
about it and Cydney Powell and Rudy Giuliani
and all these other people, you needed that
in order to get to January 6th when Trump
said, let's go to the capital.
And that's exactly what they did.
And Kayleigh McEnany participated in that
as well.
She says Biden shouldn't inflame tensions
when Trump was the guy who said when the looting
starts, the shooting starts and said, oh,
they're protesting police brutality.
I'm going to send in the military to rough
them up and can stop the the protests.
So, yes, this is the painful hypocrisy we've
seen for years now from these people.
Yes.
This is Kayleigh McEnany trying to be interesting
and relevant and failing to do that.
And, yes, this is the type of stuff that contributed
to why things are the way they are right now.
I think Caylee probably realizes the hypocrisy
of what she's saying.
Kayleigh McEnany is completely amoral, but
she's not actually stupid, but deliberately
or not, whether she knows she's lying or not.
And I think she knows she is, she's participating
in the attempt to sort of rewrite history
about what took place on January 6th, about
what the Trump presidency was and also on
the George Floyd situation.
And you have to remember that the to the modern
American right wing, the political right wing
in the United States right now, the need for
any kind of consistency or intellectual honesty
is for losers and suckers.
To use one of Donald Trump's phrases, the
only thing that matters to them is that they
own the libs, that they destroy their political
enemies no matter how they do it.
And this is why, to some degree, we have to
keep talking about Trump and the cronies from
the administration, because if we don't trump
himself and people like Kayleigh McEnany will
rehabilitate Donald Trump's image by saying
things like.
He had the greatest economy ever for three
years.
They won't talk about year four or covid,
they'll not talk about January 6th, they'll
not talk about his failed response to the
coronavirus.
That will basically be it.
And the cult of personality around Donald
Trump on social media will amplify only that
message.
It's basically gaslighting at the individual
incident level.
Like Kayleigh McEnany on Fox says presidents
shouldn't inflame tensions.
But then you remember, oh, it's part of the
bigger picture of an effort to rewrite history
about Donald Trump.
So whatever is in Cayley's mind, you know,
at minimum, even if she knows that she's being
a hypocritical liar, she's at least indifferent
to the blatant double standard of her words
publicly and her former bosses actions.
And that's already bad enough.
They will continue to do this.
They've already done it.
If you go we listen.
We looked at the interviews, I think it was
late last week with or maybe early last week
at that Trump event in Florida where Trump
supporters were interviewed about January
6th.
And they now believe I think they have actually
fallen for it.
They're not just saying it.
They have fallen for it wasn't really Trump
supporters.
It was at Tifa in disguise.
And anyway, they were peaceful.
Which conflict is like, wait a second, were
they peaceful Trump protesters or were they
not really Trump protesters?
Somehow it's both.
It's they were peaceful Trump protesters and
they were also antifa, whatever.
They've fallen for it.
And we can't allow it to become the predominant
narrative because otherwise that's how you
end up with George W. Bush now being seen
as just this friendly old man rather than
the disastrous war criminal that he actually
was.
So let's we're going to stay
on it, that's
for sure.